joining me now louise jones who's the
head of intelligence at mackenzie
intelligence services uh louise great to
have you with me again um talk us
through what exactly this extra funding
uh entails so there's a couple of key
components to this funding uh just over
300 million dollars is aimed at
financial aid that will go to kiev
directly this is for the ukrainian
government to decide what kit and
equipment they need to spend it on
another large contingency of this aid is
focused on delivering non-us ammunition
so ammunition that the ukrainian
military forces can use is
compatible with their weaponry um and
then there is also a large part of this
uh total just over 700 million uh we'll
go to other nato states this is to
enable them to be able to deliver their
kitten equipment that is familiar to the
ukrainians it's similar to what they
already use it's compatible with what
they use and it just means that they're
able to deliver this to ukraine knowing
that they have this usage
and in terms of how then the ukrainians
will put this to use what are we
expecting which regions
so the uh aim of the fighting now will
continue in the southeast so the donbass
region
mario paul is obviously a key focus for
the russian forces but the ukrainians
are also now focused on uh trying to
regain some of that lost ground in the
donbass region um there'll be focus
still uh in and around the city of izum
this is in the northeast near kharkiv
they may try and force the salient there
but the character of the conflict i
think will will start to change as we
move into this next phase what we'll
start to see is a lot more use of
artillery and the longer range weapons
up till now there's been a lot of use of
tanks very short-range fighting but what
we'll see now as the us also referred to
is moving towards that longer range
artillery strikes and what we've
possibly seen in in russia was the
ukrainians using possibly a ballistic
missile to target an oil facility inside
russia
this is a range of over 70 miles from
the ukrainian border the russians have
also hit targets within the middle of
ukraine so clearly they're now looking
at beyond just the immediate front lines
and going for those that much deeper
battle louise jones thanks so much